bonjour nicolas bonjour magali bonjour
bonne année à vous ravit vous avoir sur
ce plateau en ce début d'année dans la
matinale de rtl france alors on a vu les
déclarations d' emmanuel macron qui ont
créé une onde de choc en france en tout
cas chez 53% des français selon un
sondage et ça vous fait bien sûr réagir
ce matin mes meilleurs voeux magali et
bien entendu je regardais farhi chers
amis depuis trois jours ce pilonnage de
mépris et de cynisme gouvernementale car
ce matin nous voilà dans un sacré pastis
démocratique eh oui emmanuel macron n'a
pas attendu de digérer sa bûche du
réveillon et d'avaler sa dernière
coupette de champagne que le voilà déjà
en train d'insulter plus de seniors
français pour le plaisir et cela a été
un festival mes chers amis non vaccinés
et je cite l'oracle du mépris le popeye
de la condescendance à partir du 15
janvier vous ne pourrez plus aller au
resto vous ne pourrez plus prendre une
canne en vous ne pourrez plus aller
boire un café vous ne pourrez plus aller
au théâtre vous ne pourrez plus aller au
ciné fin de citation mais manu premier
n'a pas tout dit carphi niveau miles
avec air france et vos points sncf pour
les centres commerciaux et les grands
magasins c'est rideau les pâtes le
papier toilette et la litière du chat ça
sera dorénavant sur amazon prime et à
lanaken cet entretien dans le parisien
j'ai plusieurs mauvaises nouvelles pour
vous français de l'asu citoyenneté
officiel paria du nouvel empire des
insultes écoutez bien vous allez adorer
vous ne serez donc pas exonérer de vos
impôts vous ne serez pas exemptés de vos
cotisations sociales le contrôle
technique d'une bonne voiture mais c'est
toujours pour votre poids rhin votaient
ce coton tige vous le savez ce que vous
savez ce qu'il en est les timbres
fiscaux séparé les amendes routières
idem pour les sens vous rappellerai
toujours de 0,30 le demi litre et pour
la tva et bien c'est pareil vous allez
continuer à vous l'emplâtré et vous
financerez aussi les doses de vaccins de
millions de français car le vaccin n'est
pas gratuit contrairement ce que nous
disons doliprane qui en ce moment est un
peu tendu comme une arbalète alors c'est
pas beau la vie de sous-citoyens magali
mais je sais pas ça peut-être à vous de
me le dire en tout cas une manuelle
macro est il dû s'abstenir de faire
cette déclaration nicolas et bien ça
dépend s'il avait été soumis ainsi ou
pas tout à fait debout il ya cinq ans
dans un bar pmu de dunkerque ou de
carpentras à une heure tardive entre
deux parties de rapido bingo c'est un
truc qu'il aurait pu dire entre amis on
se laisse aller on glose on se tape
virilement sur l'épaule et on dit des
conneries mais le problème avec emmanuel
macron laisser emmerder c'est qu'il le
dit en tant que chef d'état pour définir
au mieux cette attitude il faut ouvrir
le petit robert des synonymes où l'on
trouve les objectifs suivants
inadmissibles indignes immature
inacceptable ignore d'insoutenables
intolérable est inconcevable alors vous
voyez vous avez le choix il est très
large pour décrire ce que nous vivons
car emmanuel macron ne prendra jamais la
mesure du rôle qu'il incombe un pays
comme le nôtre faire de la
discrimination une politique qu'on
impose par la force à 10 millions de
français est tout simplement indigne car
est en réalité il n'est pas là pour
protéger notre démocratie et quand
emmanuel macron dit ouvertement que ni
responsable des plus un citoyen on se
demande ce qu'on pense marlène schiappa
la ministre chargé de la citoyenneté qui
nous bassinent qu'elle ne fait pas des
soufflé au fromage d'un direct sur m6
sur les séparatismes et la citoyenneté
la question que je pose alors à quel
niveau de ces cessions se situe emmanuel
macron et pour seule réponse marlène
schiappa est capable de vous faire une
tarte aux pruneaux et aux pruneaux
facebook live qu'est ce qui pourrait se
passer alors selon vous dans les
prochains jours bien des millions de
français se sont sentis humiliés et
déchus de leur citoyenneté à juste titre
car ce mardi comme cela n'est jamais
arrivé dans la vème république emmanuel
macron a déshonoré la fonction à ab ni
abîmer la spree français a insulté les
millions de français qui a trahi dit le
plus grand serment de président le
rassemblement et l'unité est plus grave
il a créé officiellement le statut de
sous citoyens français alors qu'il n'a
pas le courage d'affronter l'ultra
violence et éradiquer un séparatisme
galopant par contre emmanuel macron est
très anti vaccins contre l'évacuation
fiscale ledun sociale la pauvreté tous
causée par l'épidémie néolibérale il n'a
pas l'épaisseur d'un président mille
manie à merveille et la violence verbale
d'un drh qui perd pied à la machine à
café il oppose un peuple qui se
fracturent tous les jours et il ne fait
pas comme rdn vacciner il est aussi le
pourfendeur notre république notre
contrat social et notre démocratie il a
insulté les non vaccinés et souhaite
leur mort sociale il aimait prise comme
il a fait un bel et gilet jaune et le
pire cette tragédie démocratique c'est
que l'opposition politique shahrani ce
conte se complaît finalement nous
d'opérette si une vraie opposition à
exister dans ce pays les parlementaires
auraient refusé de siéger dans la tente
des excuses solennelles d' emmanuel
macron et ce sera une faute très lourde
devant l'histoire alors ce matin on va
retirer parler franchement qui en mer
vraiment notre démocratie aujourd'hui
c'est ce totalitarisme qui se met
gentiment place dans une indifférence et
une docilité effrayante de très nombreux
français fossilisés valeur canapé alors
soyons tous ensemble des sous citoyens
mais soyons plus que jamais france est
fou amoureux de nos libertés et de notre
démocratie à défendre rendez vous en
avril peut-être qu'ils auront plus droit
de vote aux ailes et savoir où ça va on
se moque gentiment merci merci nicolas
merci pour c'était l'édito politique de
la matinale verte et france